all right Brittany
Brittany uh where you from originally
where'd you grow up I'm from Washington
State what part Vancouver Washington
tell me about your family
um so
my family is backwoody
um inbred weird
um
convicted felons child molesters and
just creepy people
I never really liked them so I'm afraid
to ask how was your childhood
I don't remember
you don't remember it
I remember like a few things but mainly
my memories come back to me once I relax
and my brain just like once I go back to
normality my memories will come back so
they're all suppressed memories
remember the Dynamics of your family
like you had mom and dad
um my mom is a the one that
she used to do really [__] up [__] to
me as a child and then my dad it was in
prison since I was two
and my mom
actually I think is a serial killer
murderer so
I don't know she's
she's all she's at someone's house right
now and I think she's probably killing
him
your dad was in prison for what
um I don't think he was actually in
prison he was gone for 28 years but I
don't know if he was in prison or not
do you have siblings
um I have a younger brother and an older
sister
how are they doing now
they're fine they're fine but you're
you're living here in the streets yeah
because
um when I was in
when I was at home I was leaving my
house and somebody had rigged my car up
to electrocute me for like a month
driving it
and
then they gutted my car and burned it so
my brain just got really [__] up then
I came here and they put a bunch of fake
ass [__] in my head and it's just like
no because I was a normal person before
that
it was weird I don't know how long
you've been on the streets
um I've been on the streets for a
[__] like almost a year now year and
a half how old are you
I'm 30.
you have kids I have a daughter she's
eight where's she she's with her dad
do you talk to her well yeah for my
child's sakes thank you very much
um not anymore because people [__]
that up and I can't talk to my baby
anymore I used to talk to her at eight
o'clock every night
um it's her bedtime call
oh okay
um
yeah
you came to Los Angeles when
um I walked to Los Angeles from Glendale
Glendale California yep yeah that's just
that's that's a long walk but it's
walkable but you came to Los Angeles
from
Washington State when
I don't know I've been through a major
brainwashing so my mind's just weird
drugs are part of your life now
um yeah what do you use now
I use math I use
uh fentanyl I use
oh what crack everything
how do you make money
I promise you too
so that's the go-to for a lot of women
I was thinking about Jesus
because I was
doing cool [__]
there wasn't any murder in my house
nobody's murdering people
yeah so that's
I walked here from Glendale
where do you stay now
um I'm homeless
so like last night did you sleep last
night
did I sleep last night yes I did
and where did you sleep I slept outside
the sidewalk
it's got to be rough yeah
is it hard for a female in the streets
sometimes
do you have any friends anybody you
trust
um not anymore because I went through a
thorough but brainwashing already
I think it was MK Ultra
we struggled with mental health issues
no
I've been normal most of my life I was
on one prescription pill
I was on um
buspirone
I'm not a murderer leave me alone
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done anything
differently
probably not no because I was a
Christian I believed in God
um
you know now I got saved at The Rock
Church
um
I was a good mom I was a good kid I am
what I would change is what other people
did
why would there be a baby on the [__]
ground
what do you worry about now what's your
biggest fear
my biggest fear now is that I am gonna
lose
the ability to overcome what
is in my head because of the [__] they
did to me
and it's like
I don't think that I am a bad person
I just know that they're not going to
leave me alone
I don't know I want to read palms
because I think it is the end of the
world
I honestly believe that because
Carpathia is the Antichrist so and
that's what's going to be next
and I know the world's ending so I
wanted to start helping people like if
you have doubt and you're scared about
what's going to happen
um come here and I will empathically
individually
indivisibly under God help you
to
um know what to do about every problem
specifically in your life that's making
you worry
because that's what I want to do like a
life coach yeah I want to help them
I think it'd be cool
emotionally what do you go through
a lot of [__] because my family was
severely abusive so
you remember any of the abuse
I remember it only in flashes and then
it scares the [__] out of me and I go
that didn't happen because I know it's
what's going to happen if I remember
that it's going to traumatize me so I
don't remember it
no that's not libido it's real and I
don't care
have you ever seen a therapist
no
because I was electrocuted
what is your typical day
on the streets look like
it looks like everybody I don't know
might have like a
weird idea of me that's not true but
because I can't I don't know
if you sleep you wake up in the morning
and do what
yeah I don't know
um
I sleep outside
when did you first get into drugs
I got into drugs when I was young I was
probably
12 or 13.
was it peer pressure or no it was just a
thing that everybody was doing
okay if you sit okay how much longer am
I going to be here
okay I don't feel like that you guys
have been saying and I don't feel like
that
you ever been in love before
um yeah I have
how'd that work out
it didn't because I ended up [__]
that's when I started getting
electrocuted
when I was there with him
who is electrocuting you
I didn't know who it was someone was
[__] with my car
is there something else you want to do
with your life rather than
yeah I wanted to help people
my career goal was always uh
what's your biggest regret
yeah they were saying that because
of my mom
and the child molestation station
are you sexually active do you are you
thinking about having sex with us are
you thinking about having sex with us
that's good that's good
and
really
I didn't do anything
do I think that it's funny that you're
swinging at a dead body with a baseball
bat
yes
I'm not a [__] ass serial killer and
Satan oh my God you don't even you don't
get it do you it was the end of the
[__] world
you're so stupid
okay
um I'm done can I be done now
let me just ask you one or two questions
then we're done sure
what's the roughest part of this
lifestyle for you living on the streets
probably getting raped by all my family
members and then coming out here and
having to deal with this [__]
and and not being a statistic because I
wanted to be happy
and then I'm out here dealing with this
[__] anyway
last question Brittany what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
not to fall asleep around my family
because it's the only place that I can't
fall asleep around him or I'll get
[__] in my ass
because they [__] everything in the ass
Brittany thank you so much for sharing
your story